geoffrey pions que géographe qui m'a
envoyé un moment j'ai vu que dans une
conférence débat que marcel gauchet vous
vous lamentez de ne pas avoir de bonnes
données cartographiques sur les gels et
jodie moi j'en ai le team feels une
merveilleuse étude de l'intensité des
activités facebook où on voit par région
le truc bouger être extraordinaire et
puis alors j'ai je me suis mis à
discuter type que j'avais rencontrée
dans une librairie parisienne dans une
conférence peut-être à l'époque qui est
charlie et puis que j'ai revu ensuite
veut y aura de wheelman lui aussi c'est
un jeune je ne sais plus tous les âges
de tout le monde moi y voir vous allez
voir un mot nage en fait j'en ch atteint
le stade où tout le monde est jeune
maintenant vous avez dit si tu es donc
et donc ça c'est une idée que j'avais 10
mai
monsieur tonnes à l'époque il faisait
encore appeler comme ça vous savez ce
qu'on dit ce que tout le monde dit sur
la non-participation des banlieues aux
phénomènes gilet jaune c'est pas si
simple
c'est vrai qu'ils n'ont pas participé
mais ça n'a rien à voir avec le site est
rentré de l'époque charlie sa cache une
vraie sympathie
cette cache une vraie sympathie et
d'ailleurs comment est ce que ça aurait
pu être autre chose que la sympathique
puisque quand même l'une des grandes
innovations théorique et pratique de
l'allemand macron c'était ce que
j'appelle le flash ball pour tout ce
cirque il a mené les unités de police de
banlieue qui était habitué à tirer sur
les jeunes d'origine étrangère plus ou
moins lointaines et il les a menés à
paris pour tirer et bon dernier des gens
d'origine française provincial et donc
il a fait il m'a fait une merveilleuse
analyse et est donc dont la preuve était
voulait citer le fait que y ait eu
autant de morceaux de rap c'est le
célèbre les gels et juin j'ai vraiment
géré cité mais moi je me suis contenté
d'aller chercher ce que vous citez voilà
il vous propose un petit quelques
exemples - mi-temps d'autres la banlieue
le rap sont normales pour soulager les
combats qui n'écoutent que du pop anglo
saxons ça va me faire beaucoup de bien à
larache du peuple je la vois tous les
sentiers on n'a plus un frein puis quoi
cathy chaque fin de mois on crève la
dalle je ne parle pas d'appétit il
suffisait de quelques chez les jeunes
pour que petit à petit on se bouge vonau
accès plus que ce que l'on gagne la paix
aux oublis si vous pouviez vous
prendriez nos travaux sifang ausy est
qu'on travaille plus pour gagner moins
le changement serait fade martin jol
smic n'a pas bougé de son poids leur
[ __ ] de république va couler comme le
titanic
cc désamorcer le conflit en ex black
dynamite nous sommes citoyens rentrent
chez eux avec des cicatrices sera pas
joli papillon qui sortira de la crise n
gouvernement un diplôme a pu tourner le
dos à sa patrie sont violents
comprennent à la franqui le combat ni
comment veux tu que l'on soit fier fier
de notre nation quand on veut encore
désarmé comptait tourner l'information
partout même sur la pub les toits
liberté j'écris ton nom c'est mieux
qu'un jour on est moins que les jo
triomphe teyssier je trie au fond des
mines gilet jaune et gilet jaune
voilà on a ces clichés on aurait pu
faire une émission d'une heure enfin
voyant moi j'avais les tires tu voulais
mais je vois sa propre à une fois ces
images sur est élevé mais à quel point
yoann avait raison oui ce jeu j'ai
d'emblée tout à coup ça semble une
évidence appel aux yeux c'est vraiment
mais leur impressionnant
[Musique]